with five different teams
including the hawks in his first stint
with him rose
up and under bank shot oh sweet play
from derrick rose
only one laker in double figures and
that's cruz trying to get it back door
to mclemore
taken away by bullock who normally is on
one of the stars
of the other team defensively ballrook
boy he walked right into that one didn't
he
yeah but you know that play by kuzma
minute ago for the turnover bledsoe
williamson and ingram ball
looking in finds bledsoe for the win
no and we have overtime
defensive play by rose as well
down to two he turns it over
final seconds here's rose pulls up from
three
and the knicks have their first lead of
the night
at the half derrick rose from downtown
into submission so the pacers continue
to turn it over
rolls very adept after dribble beating
the shot clock
they've got numbers of five on four
herder pulls
[Applause]
and rose with a long hit hand top and
slams it down
movie topping i'll be tapping as you
said
gaining a little bit more trust with tom
pibbeto rare minutes
but making use in transition
randall leaves it
rose to the corner barrack gets an open
shot and sticks it
that is a heck of a play watch rose
behind the back and then in the corner
uncontested
three ball for barrett to give back to
randall shot clocks inside tim but he's
got time
distance chase him to the sideline nice
touch inside derrick rose to noel for a
dunk
which will stop play for a moment that
pass was so quick it was a touch pass it
was a redeflect right there
redirect i should say and what has been
an up and down season
[Music]
rose penetrates gets inside sweet move
from derrick rose
is second on that list course mike
woodson former head coach of the new
york knicks
he was also an assistant with the new
york knicks and the baker's still down
seven they got to keep this
deficit below 10. i truly believe
because you can see the challenges right
now with them scoring the ball
as the knits possession of the knicks
they had the lakers chasing and that
left aquino open
in the corner and carl scam shows how
much time he had
quickly again with a quarter three yeah
right in front of the nick [ __ ] this
time